[Music]
so maybe that blockbuster movie lacked a
few twists and turns but here's one
snack it doesn't Whistler's has been a
movie theater favorite all the way back
since 1930 when it was first introduced
and really it's a great treat at the
movies it's something that you can share
it's something that you can snack on
throughout the movie it doesn't melt
snackers seem to agree every year they
chew through more than 1 million miles
of Twizzlers that's enough to go around
the world 45 at the twizzler Factory in
Lancaster Pennsylvania candy makers have
their hands full meeting such a demand
[Applause]
flower
with sugar or in syrup and water those
combined ingredients or slurry mix for
an hour in huge tanks the slurry then
gets pumped overhead and into cooking
kettles shortening colouring and flavor
are added and then the liquid mass is
cooking
for our finally the red licorice is
thick enough to twist and shape it shot
through several turning nozzles and
Honda giant Ford's you could say this is
where the twizzler gets its twizzle what
secret no one ever knows about wizard
there's a twist in every about eight
feet for the different sizes and shapes
twizzle products that we made once cut
boards of Twizzlers slide onto giant
carts and head to the drying tunnels
after ten hours behind these big metal
doors the Twizzlers are ready for
packaging we have first robotic apparel
whether by machine or by hand there's
not a twizzler out of place they're
carefully wrapped in those popular
one-pound bags 60 now that's a single
serving that's what we like to thing
over the years
Hershey's has gotten creative with these
twisty little candies they now come in
20 different shapes and flavors my
favorite twizzler is the chocolate
twizzler but I've been known to munch on
my fair share of strawberry Twizzlers -
the most popular is the strawberry of
course and the newest on the line
a rainbow twist six flavors six colors
all one bag watch cooking channel for
more great episodes of unwrapped
[Music]